hello and welcome to a brief clip from
this week's game spot of groans if you'd
like to watch the full episode head over
to youtube.com slash gamespot but please
be aware of spoilers so we know that
episode 10 is Circe's trial so trial by
combat Clegane Bowl has been ruled out
but we hear the high Sparrow say are you
prepared to stand trial and profess your
guilt or innocence before the seven so
they're in the scepter bay law and there
is wildfire up in there there is we also
get a look at loris mm-hmm is ghana his
pretty curls yeah he's looking pretty
beat yeah he also looks like he's gonna
crack yeah he looks like he's ready to
flip on anyone and everyone mm-hmm so so
this next scene is pretty interesting so
next episode is called the winds of
winter and this is a white Raven so this
is what the maesters send to signal the
season has changed why do they need to
do that just like look outside cuz
they're like you know really important
weathermen and they need to tell
everyone but so the season is officially
changing winter is coming well tell me
winters here yeah um but then we have
Sansa and John and they don't seem to be
getting on hmm are they going on or what
I saw was like them fortifying their new
relationship it seemed to be John doing
that yes answer seemed to be very
hesitant I mean the thing is like little
fingers back in in the action now and
there's a scene later on where they're
talking I think this might be a
situation where they're creating a new
allegiance to kind of get to scheme in
together unless it seems like sansas
making an allegiance with both of them
and they're not really all three and
talking yeah maybe will be quite
interesting um but then we get quite a
quite an unusual scene jamie is in the
twins with the phrase so we thought that
after he'd secured Riverrun he would
just hop skip and jump right back to
King's Landing to meet with his beloved
Cersei but no he's gone to see Walder
Frey for some reason for some reason and
the Walder Frey says the phrase and the
to send their regards oh no one cuts
deep which doesn't sound that good and
also I'm interested to see if there's
any fallout from Ed Muir you know being
manipulated by Jamie into getting
Riverrun back maybe maybe Jamie promised
that he would get revenge on the phrase
then as you mentioned we got Sampson
little finger love is in the air is it
it's like force love yeah I mean
admittedly one of them's in love yeah
the other ones like I just saved your
ass you bet they're the ones like I'm
not my mom leave me alone and then we
finally get this confrontation that I've
been wanting for a long time and that's
Davros in MELAS Andre hmm oh he looks it
looks heated yeah Davos is looking very
very upset I mean rightfully so but also
like tell him what you did tell him yeah
um I mean Melisandre could be like yeah
I did it she's done it before I she's
like yeah I popped out a demon she looks
very guilty about it though which is
something that she's not we're not used
to seeing mm-hmm she I mean her her
faith has been somewhat shaken recently
well then she brought go back from the
dead yeah but she doesn't seem to be
convinced that she managed it herself
like her power is faith in her own power
seems to be waning which could translate
into a waning of faith in the Lord of
Light and then we have a shot of bran
this guy again if I don't get the damn
Tower of joy reveal okay this is
ridiculous you've taken Clegane ball
away from me give me the touch I just
need to know I need to know what's in
there I mean we already kind of know
it's it yeah we know what's in there
what do we though a lot of red herring
yeah these things are changing from the
books um and then we've got um are you
afraid you're in the great game now but
blah so hopefully this means that De
Niro so get off her ass and actually get
on a boat um I really really hope also
there's a kind of weird scene where a
tire and Daario naharis that I'm kind of
wondering yeah is that a goodbye is does
he refuse to leave second songs I would
be really amazing if the actual scene is
that happening and then captain
friendzone returns at that moment I was
like I'm back baby I fixed it don't do
this to me I can't bear if he's about he
probably will return be honest yeah and
then we have a guy walking so I have
zoomed in
and stares I've looked it up on google
images that's acceptable or this door
hmm who is leaving you seem to think
it's well no because I thought it was
Masek I burn right because here you can
see a chain on here but we were sad we
compared the haircuts yeah hi bones got
a little bit of a flicking yeah curls at
the bottom so this could be land sell
lancel also has changed and yeah so
that's who I'm being on I wonder what
his role will be if he you know he's
seen firsthand the power of the mountain
could he really betray sir see again I
don't know dressing um but what I want
to do tomorrow I want to make some
predictions okay on what the last shot
of the seasons gonna be alright so
there's a few we can pick from so King's
Landing burning yes he goes full heiress
yeah I think there's a good chance of
that happening next episode I also think
the wall could come down oh no sir
that's a big one so if we know the brand
is basically broken the magic that kept
the night yeah baby cuz you got touched
God's sake bran if he goes south of the
wall I think that's the best one I think
I think that's the most likely one for
me because we've gotten quite thick into
the politics between different houses
right now and it's easy to lose sight of
the bigger picture and I think they're
going to take the opportunity to remind
people actually this is all
inconsequential because there's this
horde of frost zombies on their way yeah
another another thing maybe it could be
Lady Stoneheart no I mean they keep
saying you know oh we've never had any
conversations about Lady Stoneheart
definitely not happening definitely not
happening well they said that about Jon
Snow's death okay yeah they said that he
was like oh yeah he's dead a definite
not coming back look where we are now
Morning Joe stop yeah that's a good one
that would be a good one like you know
an eyes-open final frame kind of thing
like blood shows the final the final
thing that I think could be the last
scene want it to be I want to be the
last scene is the Tower of joy but
knowing game of thrones and knowing our
luck will probably open the door hmm
cut that yep
you